in Israel Benjamin Netanyahu is
returning to power for a record sixth
time as his government is sworn in this
morning his recent election Victory led
to the creation of a government that
includes Ultra nationalists and
religious parties that were once on the
fringes of Israeli politics
raminoscencio is tracking developments
from London Remy good morning good
morning Adriana that's right this is
being described as Israel's most
far-right government since the country
was established back in 1948. critics
say this is potentially the most
intolerant and the most insular and
that's because prime minister Benjamin
Netanyahu in order to form a governing
Coalition has now aligned himself with
Nationalist and Orthodox parties
targeting Palestinians Jews who are
non-orthodox women to prevent them from
serving in the military alongside men
and the lgbtq community now for the U.S
there are major political and cultural
considerations Mr netanyahu's party has
already vowed to expand Jewish
settlement elements in disputed regions
that includes the West Bank and the
White House has voiced opposition to
this because the West Bank has seen as a
territorial core if you will for a
future Palestinian State and then from a
religious perspective most American Jews
are in fact non-orthodox so Israel's new
government is on track to cause a Schism
in that vein all that likely to drive
more tension between the two countries
as Israel's government veers further to
the right that is expected to last a
full term and that is the next four
years Adriana
Remy great context thank you